(whooshing)
- If you want extreme happiness,
as a purebred entrepreneur,
it's all about employees,
and incentivizing the fuck out of them.
Because you're an artist,
and as an artist, you
wanna write your song.
We need to understand that
entrepreneurs are artists.
Pablo Picasso didn't want to co-paint.
(excited yelling)
You got your perspective.
(speeding up record scratching)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(jazz electronic music)
- What's up guys?
Back to biz on the Born Or Made podcast.
I am fuckin' fired up,
because I've got a guest on the show today
that honestly is fuckin'
blowing up my world.
Gary Vaynerchuk, thank you
for fuckin' being on the show.
- Thanks bro.
- Typically the way this show goes is
I pose the question whether or not
you think you got to where you are today
because you were born with
an innate ability to do it,
or you were built over
time, or made over time?
- Both.
Let's save a lot of time in this show-
- Forever, in perpetuity,
the answer's both, it's
proven that it's both.
Obviously some people
skew one way or the other.
They figured out this
nature/nurture thing forever ago,
we all keep layering on top of it.
- But wait, can I just-
- Please, please.
- So you say both?
- Yes.
- But you also say that there are
a fuck-ton of fake entrepreneurs.
- That's right.
- So if it's both,
you mean you have to be born with it
and then you build it over time?
- Nope.
I think in that example,
where you're going with that,
is entrepreneurship is cool now,
just like in 1978, being
a rockstar was cool,
and that's why every fuckin'
dude wanted to have a band.
How many of them became
The Rolling Stones?
Not a lot.
That's what we're living
through right now.
Everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur right now,
for the first time ever.
Not ever, but definitely in
contemporary pop culture,
and 98% of them will not be
successful entrepreneurs.
- But why do you think,
'cause I know what my
answer is to this question,
and I don't typically ask
the guest until the very end,
and I very rarely say what I think,
but I am 100% convinced
that you are born this way.
- Yes, but the drive that you got,
from the way your dad rolled,
since I've had you on my podcast,
or the fact that I couldn't speak English
'cause I wasn't born in America
and then I immigrated here,
is a massive fuckin' variable.
- I think adversity definitely
plays a huge role in it.
- Well let's stop right there.
If you and I were the
grandkids of each other,
instead of each other.
Full T, everything else,
we're gonna be different.
Bro, you and I have real
chips on our shoulder.
This is what I want all
these fuckers to get,
losing and shit is phenomenal.
- Oh yeah.
- Bro that's-
- 100%.
- Exactly you and me.
- Yeah.
- Growing up in Greenwich,
third-generation wealthy,
you and I are different.
I'm telling you right now we're different.
- [Michael] So I've got
another question for you.
- Do you know the level of disrespect
you and I consciously
and subconsciously have
for third-generation wealthy Greenwich?
- [Michael] Yeah, it's bad.
- We don't think they can beat us.
- It's bad.
- Forget about bad, good,
just let's go to raw.
Let's go to like winning and losing.
- But you know what, but
I actually don't even think,
it's interesting,
I don't think about that, though.
It's not like I think about,
like when somebody comes to the table
and I'm trying to do
something with somebody,
I'm like actually in the
middle of it right now.
I'm working on a project,
I got a new project that I'm working on,
and there's a dude that I'm working with
who I fuckin' love,
but he can't get out of his own way
and there's a reason why.
And the reason why is because
Pop Dukes blesses his life.
- Bro, if you don't think
that you and I, with
all our fuckin' talent,
if Pops Dukes blessed our
life, would be different,
I know you know that to be true.
- [Michael] Yeah, I get it, I get it.
- Okay, me too.
- But, question, is there,
so for everybody that's fuckin' listening,
I don't think you've ever
been asked this question.
- Okay.
- If you are that dude
or that girl, right?
- Yes.
- That has been blessed,
and you're fuckin' 25-
- Stop taking the money.
- You're 30.
- Stop taking the money, I
knew you were gonna say that.
But is there a way, is it too late?
Or can you reverse that shit?
- That's a good question.
That's a totally
different, great question.
That is a totally different
question than the first one.
Is it too late?
No, no it definitely is not.
I actually believe no, it is not too late.
Do I believe that you're 25,
think about how devastating-
Listen, by the way, I could be 100% wrong,
but I'm about to deliver a sentence
that is not fun to deliver,
because I do know that
26-year-old Sarah and Rick
are running right now on a
treadmill listening to this.
They fully know they're third-generation,
been taken care of.
They know actively right now
that mom and dad pay for Uber.
that the doorman-building
in Manhattan is paid for by mom and dad.
They know everything,
and now they're saying "Fuck,
this is a vulnerability."
They believe us, they
decide to cut off dollars,
they do wanna change, they wanna be
on their own two feet and merit-based.
Here's the problem: Yes, you can fix it.
I think you start really
getting results at 31, 32, 33.
If you're 41 right now,
I think you start really
getting results at 57, 58.
- But don't you think that this is-
- It takes time to put in the extra-
I just wanna finish the thought.
- Yeah.
- You're gonna have to put in the work.
If you've been eating like
shit and not going to the gym
for 38 and a half years, like I did,
did it take four fuckin'
good seven days a week,
eating and working out to finally form
into something at least decent?
Yes it did.
- [Michael] 100%.
- And if I started at 22 I'd
be fuckin', I'd look like you.
I'm being dead serious,
it's not super complicated.
- No, that's, and I always
bring it back to that.
But what I would say is this,
if you are 25, 26, thirty fuckin' two, 40,
and you've been living off the fuckin'-
- Teat, the teat.
- The money tree.
- Yeah.
- I think the hardest part
of that is actually starting,
'cause you don't get where you got
without going through
the fuckin' shit, right?
Like from where we came from-
- Bro you know what's
harder than what we did?
Coming from the dirt?
Is going into the dirt
when you lived in the pedestal.
- [Michael] That's what I'm saying.
So that's gotta be.
- That hurts.
- Is it reversible? I don't know.
- It's reversible if you become aware
that's it's your vulnerability.
The reason I've had some
incredible interactions
in the last couple years,
I've had people call me, cry, letters,
"Oh my God, I have subconsciously
"resented myself and my parents.
"I'm 33 years old,
"I'd never heard anybody
say 'Cut them off.'
"First you shit on my
parents for entitling me
"and I was like 'Yeah',
"and then in that same
podcast you later said,
"'Oh by the way, you know how
"I've been shitting on your parents?
"Now fuck you, stop taking the money.'
"I'd never been in a
place of accountability.
"I kept saying my parents fucked me up,
"the Upper West side fucked me up,
"Harvard fucked me up,
Goldman Sachs fucked me up.
"My friends fucked me up.
"I never was accountable in saying
"'I can stop taking the money.'"
This is gonna air fairly soon?
- [Michael] Mm-hmm.
- Cool, instead of having your parents pay
for you to go to St.
Barts this New Year's,
you could say "No."
- [Michael] Just say "No."
- But do you have the humility?
- So what you're saying is stop
taking the money, full stop.
If you wanna fuckin' put
some shit on the map-
- Yes.
- And you wanna actually
feel good about yourself-
- Yes.
- Because your line
about smiling in my Camry
or fuckin' crying in my Ferrari,
I think is as real as it gets.
- It's the realest thing I know.
- I think it's as real as it gets.
- And people that don't
have wealth are like,
"Gary, that's bullshit, only rich people
"talk about money not having happiness."
I'm like no, it's perspectives.
- All right, so another
question, "entrepreneur"?
- Yeah?
- What the fuck does that mean?
- For me, the way I've
always thought about it is
this cool game where you
live on your own two feet,
it's completely merit-based,
it's the closest thing to sports,
and you get to do what
the fuck you wanna do.
However, if you suck, you die.
- [Michael] You die.
- In that game.
You have to go get a job
is what I mean by that.
- [Michael] Okay.
- So it's the most merit-based,
which is why I think it's
fake entrepreneurship now,
because you and I didn't grow up with
this concept of raising capital.
- But how do you know if you're
a fuckin' entrepreneur or not?
Like I know how I knew because I was
fuckin' onto shit.
- And me too.
- From as early as I could remember.
- Listen, if you sold shit without knowing
why the fuck you were selling it,
before the age of 12, it's in the mix.
- So you have polarized this whole thing,
if you don't fuckin' listen to this guy,
you're fuckin' hiding under a rock
that you shouldn't be hiding under,
because you polarize this
shit in the realest way.
If you are a fake entrepreneur,
and you fuckin' know it
because nothing fuckin' works,
you have zero creativity
in your fuckin' life,
what do you do?
- Well first, and let's talk about it,
'cause listen, because
you're so cool, which is fun,
so I'm gonna assume so many
cool people listen to this.
Look, I'm so empathetic, listen,
there's a lot of people
listening right now
who have never heard of me,
so let me take a step back.
All this energy you're feeling right now,
this is not fuckin' Ritalin,
this is not fuckin' Red Bull,
this is deep gratitude
and passion to help.
That I'm so grateful, I almost feel guilty
of how much happiness I have
because of circumstance,
of parenting, and
entrepreneurship, and immigration,
and bad school, and all this stuff.
Look, I'm empathetic to the kid
that we just punched in the gut who knows
that he has or she has,
and this skews a little bit more male,
but it goes both ways,
has "entrepreneur" in
their Instagram account
because that's a good thing
to say at Eugene's Spot
at 2:00 in the morning,
like it's really cool.
You know, what do I say?
It's gonna lead you down depression,
in the same way that
your parents forced you
to be lawyers and doctors and engineers,
and all those immigrant kids
are deeply depressed at 42,
the reverse is about to happen.
All these kids that are using their bio
and saying they're an entrepreneur,
but deep down know they can't do it,
they need to get off that fuckin' drug.
They have to, self awareness-
- So wait, but one other thing-
- Real quick, I wanna say one last thing?
- Yeah.
- Self awareness and
humility and accountability
are the greatest paths to happiness,
and nobody wants to do that.
- Can I tell you what I think
the greatest path to happiness is?
- Please.
- Straight up?
- Fitness and fuckin' wellness.
- I love that.
- I'll be honest with you.
- No, that's great, I love that.
- Out of everything in my life,
so I just sold a bunch
of equity in a company.
- Okay.
- And took one of the larger checks
I've ever taken in my life.
- Which is always a fun moment.
- It's a fun moment.
Guess what?
This was the most polar,
this happened last week.
I was sitting in my fuckin'
car, and I had just,
I had just done this thing.
- And it's in your account, you see it?
- And it's in my account.
- Which is always a funny
part when you see it.
- Nothing.
- Changed.
- I believe that.
- I mean nothing, I
mean nothing from like-
- You didn't buy anything.
- I took the fuckin' train,
I didn't buy anything.
- I got it.
- Nothing.
- You know why?
You're in a good space-
Let me say this,
what would have happened 17
years ago if that check hit?
- Yeah, it'd be probably
a different story.
- That's it, let's talk about that.
The reason nothing changed is you're in
a fuckin' incredible spot right now.
- But can I tell you why
I'm in an incredible spot?
Because I wake up at 5:00 every morning,
I'm in the gym at 5:15.
- You found your process.
- And that's it.
You ready for this?
You know why I'm in an incredible spot?
'Cause I wake up every
morning making pretend
that my parents or
children died that night.
No listen, everybody has their thing.
Some people are in an incredible
spot because they work out.
Some people because of the
type of food they now eat.
Other people because of a mentor.
Listen, one of the things
that I'm so grateful for in my life,
some people are in a great spot
because I fuckin' penetrated their dome
over the last four years
'cause they've consumed
80,000 fuckin' hours of my shit,
and I did it for them.
Just like my mom did it for me,
just like some people did it for you,
the dude that fuckin' helped you when
you were fuckin' growing, you know?
- Mm-hmm.
- I love that shit.
- Let me just give you something, dude.
So by the way, it's this
motherfucker's birthday tomorrow.
- It's true.
- And on your show.
- Yes?
- We talked about doing something,
and we didn't do it, until now.
- Oh my God, I'm so pumped!
I'm gonna wear this tomorrow.
Is this medium though, I need a medium.
- Of course it's a medium.
- Yes, you're the best.
"I love my fuckin' parents, but."
Yep, I remember that moment.
(laughing)
I gotta go look back at it.
I don't think we clipped it.
We didn't clip it, we
need to clip it, Jason.
Remind me, 'cause I remember
it was a huge moment.
What was the point we were making?
- You had asked me a question
and it was something about my parents
and I was like, you know,
"I love my fuckin' parents, but."
'Cause I had moved out of
my parents' house at 15.
- Yeah yeah.
- And then you were like "What was it?"
and I was like "I love
my fuckin' parents, but,"
and you were like, "Stop!"
- Let's make T-shirts.
- Yeah.
Everybody says that, and my big thing
on that is take the "but" out,
and whatever the fuck they did,
alcoholics, beat you, I mean
there's some extreme shit,
and then you've got people
who hate their parents
on some lightweight shit.
Most of the emails I get
are one of the two extremes.
"Gary, you don't get it though!"
Like heinous shit that I'm actually
not even gonna repeat it here,
like I'm so uncomfortable,
like real gnarly shit.
Or entitlement.
Like it's funny to me,
the person that says
"I love my parents, but
they paid for everything
"and now I resent them
at 27 cause I've realized
"I am a zoo animal,"
for them that's as real
as the person that had an alcoholic parent
that punched them in the face,
'cause you both are affected.
It's your reality.
Who do we get to judge
which one's better or worse?
As a matter of fact if
you look at suicide rates,
a lot more of the fuckin' zoo animal
than the one that got punched
in the face, it's crazy.
- Yeah, I think that's honestly-
- Everybody wants-
I apologize 'cause I'm
passionate about this.
Everybody wants to make
their thing the worst.
You don't get it, I'm an immigrant.
You don't get it, I'm an African American.
You don't get it, I had
a dad who was bipolar.
cancer when I was four.
Everybody needs more compassion,
everybody's got shit.
Everybody's trying to prove which person's
suppression or shit story is worse,
and my whole thing is let's go reverse.
Let's just acknowledge
nobody's got it great,
and everybody's potentially got it great.
- The one question that
I get asked all the time,
consistently, over and over again,
how do you get fit, how do you work out,
how do you balance life
and fuckin' business?
- Accountability.
- I think that there's
a very simple answer
that is really common sense,
that is so fuckin' crazy,
that people actually have the audacity,
a word that you've been
saying a lot, to ask.
If you want something,
there's only one way,
in my opinion, there's
only one way to get it,
and you've gotta fuckin' do it.
Period.
That's it.
- Can't read about push-ups.
- That's it.
- Bro, you're preaching.
- But, I think everybody
who just heard that,
and this is where my conversation
on this issue has evolved,
this is why I got into judgment.
Do you know why so many
people that weigh 413 pounds
don't go to the gym, who can't
afford a private trainer?
They're worried about
the judgment on day one.
- Well I think you're right.
I think that that's why
fuckin' at home fitness
is taking off, right?
- 100%, but you know how many people
can't be accountable to just themselves
and actually need the gym environment?
- [Michael] So what do
you think that is though?
I do wanna talk about that for a sec-
- High school.
- [Michael] Oh my God.
- It's high school.
- [Michael] So this is the question
that I fuckin' have for you.
- Go ahead.
- And this is a question that I think
is so fuckin' important.
Totally unrealistic.
Let's just put yourself in an
unrealistic bubble for a moment.
I think high school is fuckin' bullshit.
I just do, I think high school's bullshit.
- Go ahead.
- I have not applied a single
thing that I fucking learned
in high school to anything I do today,
outside of networking and socializing.
- Okay.
- That is the one thing
that I think high school.
So if you were given an opportunity
to change the curriculum
for today's fucking human
being, in the high school,
in high schools across the
country, what would you do?
- I would flip the model
of one curriculum for all
to individual curriculums
to everyone at scale.
You and I would have loved high school
if all of our classes were
entrepreneurship, networking.
- [Michael] Maybe.
- No, no.
- Look at this.
- Listen.
- I got a bag of tricks here.
- Go ahead.
- One other thing.
So I was looking for shit
because I thought it would be fun
to have some shit on set
with you and I found this,
my high school diploma.
- You found it.
- And in my high school diploma,
you wanna know what I found?
- Report card?
- My final report card.
- Let's go.
'Cause you know how proud I am of my shit.
- Look, just look.
- You got a class rank as bad as mine?
I was 243 out of 254.
- Look at my classes, at my absences.
- Holy shit.
- Dude.
- Excessively.
Economics 29.
Yeah, but like economics
sucked in the school way.
- I didn't show up to this class.
I just never went.
Like this was, what made me
think about this question
and why I wanted to ask this to you
was how can I, what would change that?
- You know what's awesome?
Everyone, pay attention to this,
they break it up into three sections,
the audacity that our
man Michael rolled with.
In section one, the beginning of the year,
four absence, six lates.
Now let's build on that.
Section two, five absence,
only one more, 17 lates.
(laughing)
So you see an entrepreneur
here because he's evolving,
he's understanding how much he can do.
Third, nine absence, so
he matched the first two,
and 25 lates, did more than
the first two combined.
Obviously, it gets a little warmer.
Ah, I understand, you were a pretty boy,
I know what you were
doing in fuckin' spring.
- But what this said to me was like,
"Yo there is an opportunity."
I go hard and extreme on shit I love.
- Correct.
- If there's something I
love I am the most extreme.
- Bro, if somebody, and
again, back to this,
by fourth grade, fifth grade,
we know that Sally is type
A, wants to be a lawyer,
wants to do this, and let's
give her a curriculum.
If we find little Gary and
little Michael, let's get them
into something far more
creative and entrepreneurial.
- [Michael] Let's just hunt a little bit.
- I mean I really want
to pull it, you know.
I wanna pull it.
- This was, I was like, you know what,
I wanna fuckin' hunt
with Gary for a moment,
and if there's a possibility to do it.
- Now this is '90.
This is not '89, I know.
- No Griffies, no Griffies.
But Juan Gonzalez.
John Olerud, Gonzalez,
I got a Mookie Wilson.
Big shout out to Mookie (mumbles).
- [Michael] Mookie Wilson was my guy.
And it's also weird.
- That's a Blue Jay, not a Met.
- There it is.
That you're a Jets and Yankee fan,
which is a weird fuckin' combo.
- It's a weird combo, but not for some.
It's a weird combo because most-
- Because Queens is fuckin' Mets.
- Yes, that's right.
But as you know-
I pulled a fuckin' Juan Gonzalez.
- Did you?
- I literally called the best
card and fuckin' pulled it.
- Did you?
- I pulled a Juan Gonzalez fuckin' rookie.
- [Michael] Of course he
fuckin' pulls the best card!
- Bang!
Literally said this was the
one and got it first pack!
Let's fuckin' go!
- Happy birthday GV, my guy!
- Thank you, here's why,
I was born in Russia.
So because I was born in Russia,
I didn't have my grandfather
who grew up in Queens
telling me on Mets and Jets.
Not only was I born in
Russia, so I have to start,
my dad didn't know American sports.
I'm the first, I'm the
patriarch of my family's fandom.
And I grew up in Jersey,
which was very split.
- [Michael] Jersey was very split.
- So that's how it happened.
By the way it sucked
cause I'm an '80s baby,
the Mets were much better
than the Yankees in the '80s.
- Let me tell you the funniest
fuckin' story of all time.
- Please.
- So my father was born in Queens,
I'm fourth-generation New York City,
I am the first non Queens kid.
How are we doing on time, we got time?
- Great, I'm actually taking
a photo while you're talking.
By the way, everyone's like
"How do you make content?"
I'm like, you just make it!
I'm literally taking a photo
of this Juan Gonzalez card
and I'm gonna post it on
Twitter while you're talking.
Make!
- So 1986, the Mets won the Series.
My father never missed a
Mets game ever, ever, ever.
We could be anywhere,
and he had a little
fuckin' radio with him,
he never missed a Mets game.
- That's amazing.
- 1987, Mets were in the
playoffs, and Darryl Strawberry-
- '87 or '88?
Did they make the '87 playoffs?
Are we talking about-
Is it against the Dodgers
when Sosa hits the home run?
Cause that's '88.
- No,
it was when Darryl Strawberry-
It was in '87, maybe
it wasn't the playoffs,
it was in '87, Strawberry
charged the mound.
- Okay.
- I don't remember what game it was.
- Go ahead.
- But it was towards
the end of the season.
Strawberry charged the mound,
Darryl Strawberry was my god.
- Yeah, I mean he was the guy.
- He was my god.
- Of course.
- And he charged the mound,
and he's a fuckin' fast motherfucker,
an athletic motherfucker, he got,
he like actually charged the mound,
and actually laid some
fuckin' punches in there.
And I looked at my dad
and I said "Dad, why did
"Darryl Strawberry just beat that guy up?"
And I very clearly remember
my father looking over
and being like, "Son, Darryl
Strawberry's a full-on
"drug addict," and that was it.
- Wow!
- I became a Yankee fan overnight.
- What?!
- I dropped everything.
I was like, "A drug addict?"
And that was when like Darryl-
- Yeah!
- [Michael] That was like
when fuckin' the (mumbles)-
- Dude, bro, I've never, listen to me,
I'm the byproduct of Nancy Reagan.
I've never done a single drug in my life,
because the propaganda during
that time was so intense.
- [Michael] Oh, it was so intense!
- And my mom made that religion,
and I was a good mama's
boy, and like I didn't-
I used entrepreneurship for
escapism, I didn't go there.
And like, to this day, I turn 44 tomorrow,
have never, I mean sugar and
coffee, but like anything,
I've never smoked a cigarette.
I've never-
Yeah, obviously.
But by the way, that's a fun one.
If my dad didn't have a
liquor store, I'm convinced.
I didn't have a beer
until I was 21 years old.
I was crazy straight-laced
on complete drug,
and by the way sex too.
- So in high school
were you a straight-laced guy?
- Straight-laced.
I was scared shitless of
sex 'cause of Magic Johnson.
I was completely convinced
that if I had sex one time-
- You were gonna get AIDS.
- That I would have AIDS.
- [Michael] Wow.
- Yep.
I was super not "fun" or "cool"
in that my personality,
I was awesome in my personality traits.
I was addicted to the fucking
game of entrepreneurship.
I was a character, a class clown,
popular for my kindness,
like I crossed over genres.
I like did a lot of good things,
but I was not cool
because I was absolutely
not a drug or sex kid,
and that is the requirement
of cool in high school.
- Yeah, no doubt.
- That is the cost of entry.
- When I came into high school,
I was young, I was 13,
and by second semester of high school,
13 years old, I had just turned 14,
I was a complete animal.
- Yeah, I remember our podcast.
- And it fuckin' changed overnight for me.
- Yeah.
- And then by the end of
my fuckin' freshman year,
I was selling drugs to my
whole entire high school.
- Yeah.
- And it was fuckin' nuts.
- Yeah, no I get it.
- All right, I wanna quick-fire some
because I wrote these
questions out and I think that
it's important to get them.
So, if the Jets were winning consistently,
like had won a couple of Super
Bowls in the last five years,
10 years, would you still be on the path?
I believe that you would
not be on the path.
- I believe that I would
- You would not be on the path.
- I believe if the Jets win a
Super Bowl before I buy them,
then there's a chance that-
- [Michael] You're gonna
wanna buy the Knicks?
- Yes.
Yes I believe that to be true.
- [Michael] Wow.
- I dropped the Yankees and Rangers.
Listen, I'm gonna post this,
'cause I gotta find it,
I think I'm going to my
parents this weekend actually.
My yearbook in high
school has more references
to the New York Rangers than the Jets.
Yeah, I think you got the scoop.
- I knew it.
- I'm about the hunt.
How about this, when I was scared of sex?
In high school, my great moments were
just getting the girl to like me.
It was the chase.
- 100%.
But I think that's classic.
I think on a large scale, like what I say
to fuckin' myself and everybody else,
if you don't learn to love
the heart and the hurt,
you're fucked.
- 100%.
- If you don't actually love it,
- No, no.
You have to love the process.
- You have to love, for
me, it's about learning
to love the heart and the hurt.
I just went through this
not awesome situation
with a business, and everybody
was like, "Oh I'm sorry."
I'm like, sorry?
- It's fuckin' awesome.
I love it.
- I'm like, sorry?
- Bro.
You know what I would have been great at?
UFC.
- [Michael] Why?
- 'Cause everybody loses.
I would have been a great UFC fighter.
I would have loved being 24 and 8.
And like be at the bar and
be like, "Yo remember when
"I knocked out Tito, but
remember when fuckin' Shane
"choked me the fuck out?"
Like it's merit.
- Yeah.
All right, let's keep going.
So I think that that's pretty interesting.
Your biggest burn in business?
Can you talk about that?
- Well, look, I'm 44 years old tomorrow,
and I built one massive
business for my dad
and left with zero dollars.
And I built another
massive, massive business
and I'm buying out my brother.
- But you must have some
situations that just like
fuckin' left a really
bad taste in your mouth?
I'm not talking about like business,
like failing in a
business, I'm talking about
just like burn, partnership, anything.
- I'm going right to it.
The family business is
the best and hardest part.
Everything else is kind of easy.
I lose money all the time.
I start divisions and new concepts.
I wrote a check into somebody's
startup for $250,000,
and this is all my own money.
Do you know how much $250,000 is to me?
I made $40,000, $50,000,
$60,000 every year in my 20s.
This is like an enormous
amount of money to me, still,
and the company failed
within the first year.
Unlimited, I hire people
that fail all the time.
Here's the one thing that
people don't understand
about being good at something.
I'm never gonna make a business deal
that puts me into death, so
everything's a micro cut.
There's a very big difference
between breaking your arm
and dying in a car accident.
So when people are like
"What are your failures?"
I'm like, you mean breaking arms?
But they want some sort
of story where you,
I will always save too much money.
- [Michael] All right, fuck it,
so we'll move onto the next one.
- But by the way, real quick,
just to add to everybody.
Every day, we got fired
today from a big client
for some bullshit, today.
Gonna lose $1.3 million in revenue
that I now have to make up for next year.
I pay bills.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- You know, every day.
Every fuckin' day.
- So for me, in business,
whether I'm the CEO of the company or not,
my number one hurdle is my CFO.
- 100%.
- Just number one hurdle.
So, for marketers, guys
like you and I, brand guys,
culture guys, community
guys, long-game guys.
How do you approach
your CFO with a fuckin'-
- Conviction and compassion.
(slapping noise)
Missed it, it's right there.
Conviction and compassion.
- [Michael] Conviction and compassion?
- That's right.
I'm compassionate for you CFO,
that you've found yourself
in the precarious spot,
that you're in one of those 5% places
where you're not actually the boss.
And let me say that nice and
slow for everybody listening,
because most people on
the other side of this
don't know this truth.
Most companies are actually
run by the CFO, not the CEO.
- [Michael] 100%.
- I don't have a board.
I'm not held to publicly-traded
company dynamics.
I have 100% control, thus, this
is one of those rare places
where my CFO has to conform
to not having power.
On the flip side, I have compassion.
His whole career has been under a place
where he's had the-
- Don't die.
- So, I want him to get reconciled.
Even though we're in year
three now with this CFO,
I'm patient.
- So most people don't have
that fuckin' ability, right?
So like if there is a
team within a company
that feels so passionate about something?
- Yes.
- And the CFO is like "No,
we're simply not spending
"the fuckin' money on that,"
and they don't have the control
to necessarily say, "Well
actually, we are spending
"the money on that."
How do you propose an
idea to a CFO that you-?
- You don't.
- [Michael] You just don't?
- You do not, because a CFO,
she or he is a certain animal.
You're not gonna convince
a tiger to start flying.
It is that binary.
You can, by the way, do
you know how many people
listen and be like, "He's wrong."
And then I'm gonna answer to everybody
on the other side of this
podcast, "You're right."
I'm sure you can point to a time where,
after four and a half months,
two years of conversation,
finally you were able
to get something done.
Do you know how much time
you wasted on the other 99%
of times that you tried
to get something done
that could not get done 100%
because they would not waver?
- It's fucked up man, I think-
- It's actually not fucked up.
It's actually kind of like
Republicans and Democrats,
which is like look, everything's the best
when it's in the middle.
Culturally, right now
in our politics we're,
and the reason everyone's feeling tension
is we're pulling away from each other.
Same in business.
CEO, CFO. Right?
Especially CEO, founder, visionary.
She's always gonna be on the offense.
It's that CFO views themselves as
the person that keeps her in line.
- Editor
- Editor, and a good CFO
actually comes from a good place.
They're like "Wow, she's so
dynamic, I'm gonna be back here
"making sure nothing
gets too crazy so that
"she can see her vision through."
- Right.
- I believe that, there's
a lot of great CFOs.
So you have, that's when
a CEO and CFO work great.
They've got vision and
compassion for the CFO,
CFO feels like he's empowering
or she's empowering her vision,
but that still doesn't
mean that four times a year
they get to a crossroads where the CEO,
she thinks this is the
one idea that's gonna
take us to the moon, and
the CFO goes "Fuck, this is
"the idea that can fuck us,"
and now they have friction.
- Right, so I think the
question that comes, typically,
is talk to me about ROI on
this fuckin' initiative?
- This is why it goes back to
who actually has the leverage.
I don't have that conversation.
- [Michael] Right.
- I'll appease it,
out of respect.
- Right.
But I think it's really sad,
because I feel like the way things-
- No it's not.
- No, what's sad is that like-
- Let me tell you why
it's not sad, Michael,
you'll appreciate this.
The reality is this is
why parenting is so hard.
It's actually a place where
the nature of having a child
leads to two cooks in the kitchen.
But in reality, I'm sure if everybody
takes a step back right now,
one of the parents is still
the 1A parent decision maker.
Well guess what? That's
how businesses are.
- Are you the 1A in your house?
- I am not.
- I am not either.
- But I'm the 1A in my business.
And that's it, like
there is no partnership.
Decisions are only made when
somebody makes a decision.
- So it's interesting,
because I was thinking-
- And by the way, real
quick, it's a partnership,
but still somebody has to make a decision.
- Yeah, yeah, no I agree.
But, in business partnership, classically,
people are taught that you should find
a partner that compliments
your skill set, right?
So you're great at fuckin' marketing
and this person is great at
fuckin' financials, right?
Because the marketing guy's typically
not necessarily thinking
about the fuckin' P&L,
and the P&L guy-
- I agree with you.
I don't think it's partnering
with somebody like that,
I think it's hiring people.
- Hiring, 100%.
Going forward that's it.
- That's it!
- For me, that's it.
I'm 38, like you say, I've got another
fuckin' 80 years to go.
Right? We're fuckin' doing it.
- No, this is why we're
gonna be unstoppable.
No really.
I think the fact that our generation
is having these thoughtful conversations,
bro, I swear to God on everything,
the Jets, my kids, you know, society,
I think the biggest business I build,
probably will get started in my 60s.
I'm just gonna be so unstoppable.
Experienced.
- I haven't even started, I agree.
- I can't believe how good I was at 25.
Listen, five years in I take a business
from three to $60 million with no money.
I was an all-star.
I'm the LeBron, Kobe type.
I'm very comfortable
saying out loud right now,
look, yes, I'm gonna be in the mix.
People are gonna conversate
about me in 50 years
as a real fuckin' player.
Yet, that 26-year-old
that had all that talent
is a schlemiel compared to the
guy sitting here right now.
Experience fuckin' matters.
- And imagine, 30 years from now.
- Oh!
- All right, I got a few
more of these questions
that I think are important.
Is there, these are sort
of more restaurant-focused.
- Let's go.
- Happy hour, thoughts?
- Yes.
I think it's a brand that feels old
and just changing the
terminology and a single tweak
about it could start a whole revolution.
- Suggestion?
- If you're a 5:00 to 6:00 p.m.,
or whatever hours you're trying to drive,
A, give it a completely different name,
and incentivize it in a way that isn't
just predicated on better pricing.
- So potentially service?
Something about the service?
- Create something called "72 Minutes."
And it's this whole
thing called "72 Minutes"
and it starts at 5:00
p.m. and ends at 6:12,
and then now that we've
created the container,
in my ideation and brainstorming
with you here right now,
now we say, "Okay, besides good pricing,
"what could we do from an
experience, from a programming,
"from some left-field other
third idea that really drives
"people running out of
their fuckin' office
"to be in this 72 minutes?"
- I like 72 Minutes, it's a good one.
- Thank you, man.
- Digital marketing and restaurant space.
Outside of traditional marketing,
like old-school fuckin'
TV commercials that
nobody in the restaurant
business, at my level,
can even fuckin' begin and would never
wanna do today anyway,
outside of the Super Bowl,
like you said-
- Content at scale.
Talk to me about that-
- Both, so let's talk about a trendy place
'cause you come from that kind of world,
really being hip and smart about it.
Not just how good the scene looks,
that is the one-dimensional
move that everybody makes.
Look how cool it is here.
So that's your first Instagram post,
but your second one is a 2
minute 19 second Instagram TV
of somebody making the shrimp cocktail
and we get to know that Juan is here.
Like, "Is Juan back there?"
- Yeah, but straight up?
- Yeah.
- I do that.
- Okay.
- And I know a lot of
fuckin' people that do that.
My question is, it's not ecom,
so there's no click-through
in the restaurant world, right?
Outside of making a reservation,
which fuckin' 90% of
the time gets canceled,
what can restaurants,
somebody's coming up, brand-new,
wants to launch a restaurant,
young entrepreneur,
actually fuckin' hustler, gets it,
understands the digital space.
What should they do to get
butts in seats in restaurants?
- Either, but listen, you just said to me
you play basketball and
I'm saying be LeBron.
I know that you fuckin' post on Instagram,
I'm talking about every
fuckin' nuance underneath that.
I don't wanna leave, I'm gonna give you
another one for your answer,
but let me say it very
clearly 'cause this is what
I spend a lot of time looking at.
You can absolutely drive your business,
if you have a proper
TikTok, Twitter, Facebook,
YouTube, podcast, LinkedIn strategy,
and you're pumping out 100
pieces of content at scale
against different demographics.
What restaurant in America
right now is casting
African-American actors
to be in the content
of how good the nightlife looks there
and then running it against ads,
against only African-Americans
within a one-mile radius?
Let me save you time, goose fuckin' egg.
So before we go over, "I
do that, others do that,"
first do the thing-
- No, no-
- No, no, real quick.
But it's important, it's
gonna help people listening.
First that, number two, and this is it,
either do the thing that's
current, completely best
or break the rules.
Let me give you an example.
I've been thinking about starting
a restaurant called Subscription.
Which is exactly what it is.
You have to pay a subscription fee
with a heavy cancellation fee.
That drives guaranteed revenue for me
so I can staff against it, and you decide
if you're gonna show-
- And what you just come and
eat, you pay a monthly fee.
- Yup.
- And then you just come
and eat whatever you want.
- Yup.
- Everything is fuckin',
there's no transactions-
- And I've been playing with names.
I called it Subscription 24,
which means you get to
go there twice a month.
It's a good fuckin' idea.
- [Michael] Fuckin' smart.
- Thank you.
- [Michael] People have been
doing it in the coffee space.
- Bro!
- [Michael] So there's like a
subscription mail-in coffee.
- And by the way, between
72 and Subscription 24,
in this podcast, you've
just uncovered an insight
that only I, in the last year or two,
have realized about
myself because of my team,
which is I have never
given credit to my own self
on how creative I am within business,
and that's why I innovated.
In hindsight it makes sense,
but think about the two things I just-
by the way I just ideated them.
I say, "I've been thinking about,"
those are passing thoughts.
There's never been a time
that I've put to words
Subscription 24, I just know
that breaking the framework
is how you win that game.
Here's what I'm good at.
If I had heard-
- [Michael] Can I ask you just-
- Look, let me finish this thought
'cause I really wanna get it out.
This is what I always do.
If I saw on Twitter or if
you, or Aton, or Eugene,
or Noah texted me and
said, "Hey, have you heard
"about Subscription 24?"
I would do what you did,
'cause you're smart,
"Fuck that's smart."
That's how I try to come up with ideas.
By the way, people love fuckin' new shit.
Do you know many people love,
somebody's gonna go and execute this idea
right now that's listening,
which makes me happy.
- Yeah, but you know what the fucked up
part about that idea is?
You're fuckin', you're
at a ceiling, right?
- No you're not.
- So there's a subscription,
can they spend more
money when they're there?
Like is there tiers for it?
- How about this?
What if it's so perfect that
you just have 8,000 locations globally?
You can also change the pricing.
You can put in a word that we will always
give our subscription
price a 12-month preview
to a new pricing structure.
To your point, we can ideate
and say the food's locked,
alcohol isn't, that's where
all the upside is anyway.
You could go in perpetuity on this.
We're four minutes into
brainstorming this idea.
(laughing)
- Partnerships, I think, are the hardest
fuckin' thing on the planet,
like the hardest fuckin'
thing on the planet.
- Couldn't agree more,
couldn't agree more.
It's not human-based.
- So do you, are you, when you say that,
'cause you said that
on the podcast as well,
partners or no partners?
- No partners.
- Period, no partners?
- Period, no partners.
- Ever?
- Ever.
Meanwhile, I've only had partners.
Now I've had family members.
If you want extreme happiness
as a purebred entrepreneur,
it's all about employees,
and incentivizing the fuck out of them,
because you're an artist,
and as an artist, you wanna
write your song, the end.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- We need to understand that
entrepreneurs are artists.
Pablo Picasso didn't wanna co-paint.
- Well, so the point that I
was trying to make earlier was-
- I like that one, by the way.
No really, that was a good one.
- That's a very good one,
Pablo Picasso didn't wanna co-paint.
I'm married to my wife
a long fuckin' time.
- Yes.
- We're together 15 years,
we're married almost 13 years,
and it's an incredibly
awesome, healthy relationship.
We happen to think very much alike.
If we did not think a lot alike,
it probably wouldn't work out.
- You also have your outlets,
where you guys get to be the
Alpha within your framework.
- Well she fuckin' runs the show.
- Yeah.
- That's just the straight-up
truth and I'm cool with that.
- And she doesn't call you to tell you
how to run your business.
- She doesn't tell me
how to run my business.
She would like to see me a
little bit more but that's-
- That's a whole different thing.
- That's another thing.
- But the reason you guys are fulfilled
is you get to be a
non-partner in your craft,
and then you come together and be partners
in your relationship.
- But the one thing that I think
is interesting in business,
because it's very fuckin'
similar to a marriage.
Very, very similar in
terms of the amount of time
you spend together-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The decisions that you
have to make together.
- Tons, tons.
- So, in business they
tell you to find somebody
who thinks totally fuckin' different.
- They don't.
They do, and then the book
comes out three years later
that says, "Find somebody
who thinks exactly like you."
You just hear that part because
you know it's wrong for you.
And I'm sure right now
somebody's banging on
the steering wheel saying,
"These two fuckin' morons!
"I have had a 37-year successful
partnership with Barry,
"and these two fuckin' idiots don't know
"what the fuck they're talking about!"
You're right.
This is all self-awareness,
it's all contextual
and it comes down to that.
This all starts with being self-aware.
You know how many people
are awesome partners
because they love being a
1B and they want the 1A.
AJ was a great partner to me.
He knew I wanted the
limelight, I wanted the say.
There's a lot of different versions.
- Yeah.
- I'm a great partner too.
I didn't give a fuck about
the money, nor do I still,
as much as having to say in the limelight.
I'm doing it for the craft.
I'm doing it for the Hall of Fame,
I'm not doing it for the money,
which is why I don't
have anywhere close to
as much money as I've actually earned.
- Do you think that
doing it for the money,
is there any long-term
fuckin', is there a shelf-life
for doing it for the money though?
- Yeah, I hate that game, bro-
- But is there a shelf-life for it?
- Honestly, I don't know,
everybody's different.
It's unbelievable how vulnerable-
- [Michael] How many athletes do you think
do it for the money?
- A lot, because,
athletes are a little
bit interesting to me.
A lot of athletes, it's
their number one out,
financially, in comparison
to alternatives.
Do you know many people don't realize
how many athletes hate being an athlete?
- You said that the other day.
- I did.
- So what is that conversation like?
- It's interesting, this
is why I love VaynerSports.
I'm thoughtful, I love this shit, right?
So it's really fun.
They know that this was
the way to make $11 million
and they're also smart.
A lot of the athletes like
hearing what I'm saying right now
'cause they're like, "Right, Gary's right.
"At 34 I'll be done with this,
I'll have 13 in the bank,
"and then I can go be
an artist, a teacher."
So it's kind of cool.
I think the modern-day
athlete is far more thoughtful
than a lot of people think.
I will tell you, one of
the most misbranded things
in our current pop culture
society, is athletes.
They are dramatically better guys and gals
than people give them credit for.
They're dramatically more thoughtful,
but people wanna go into
the drugs, beating the girl,
like the headline-
- That's just fuckin' life, right?
Like that's unfortunate human condition.
- But ready?
That's the reverse of how
we look at Wall Street.
Today, Wall Street will do far more
worse human things than athletes.
That is not the perception in
mainstream American culture.
- [Michael] You don't think so?
- No way for that.
- [Michael] Today?
- No, no, even today.
- [Michael] Entertainment?
- I'm talking real shit.
I'm talking beating
women, I'm talking rape,
I'm talking, no, I do not believe that.
I believe they think that they're bros
and bad fuckin' guys who
just care about money,
and they have hookers and coke,
but truly like going to jail, like dark.
- Aaron Hernandez.
- Yeah, that's right.
No, I don't.
No, I don't believe that's a perception.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- I think the athletes are
grossly, I'm blown away.
And we're recruiting these
kids when they're 20.
Think about how much of a
knucklehead you were, right?
I'm telling you, 99 out
of 100 of these kids
are great fuckin' kids.
- I would love nothing more
than to sit down with
Saquon Barkley and fuckin'-
- Well, he's obvious.
(laughing)
No, no, he's obviously awesome.
He's an amazing kid.
I'm actually talking like, at scale.
- [Michael] Just like the masses.
- Yeah, because that's
how I look at it now.
I have a good read on 300-
- Like the judgment on athletes
after a fuckin' post-game interview.
- Correct, or listen,
what about appearance?
I mean let's call it what it is.
Overlaying America's racial issues,
overlaying the fact that
these kids are swaggy
and they're always gonna be
trendy with their clothes,
which inherently seems not conservative,
which is fear-based.
Slang, all of it.
- [Michael] What did you think about
the Giants passing on Haskins?
Did you think they were
gonna pick Haskins?
- I have to be very transparent now.
We recruited very heavily Daniel Jones
before he was a major prospect.
- I asked you that on Twitter.
- Daniel Jones sat in VaynerMedia's
office, we were on it.
Before he was a major
prospect, we were on it.
Big shout-out to Brian
McLaughlin on our team, on it.
We were like, "This is the guy."
So I actually think he's a
better quarterback than Dwayne,
and I think Dwayne's a nice
athlete but I just think
Daniel's gonna be a
better NFL quarterback.
So when he gets picked,
Giant fans freak out,
I get texts, I reply to all of them.
We missed out on this kid by a
hair, I wanted him super bad.
- What did you think though?
Were you like, "Giants
are gonna pick Jones"?
- I thought Daniel Jones
should've went number one
in this NFL draft.
That's what I thought.
- What did you think about Giants picking
Barkley over Darnold two years ago?
- I thought that was mistake.
- You did?
- And I still do.
- Really.
- Yes, I do.
- Fuck.
- I could be wrong and I think right now-
- Running backs don't win
Super Bowls, quarterbacks do.
Are you stoked about Darnold?
- Stoked, a couple things on this one.
Barkley is a big-time running
back, not just a running back.
- Could be the best ever.
- Number two, right now Darnold,
between mono and the way
the Jets are playing,
everybody who's listening is like,
"This guy's homering it,"
they don't realize that
I've not liked a single Jets
quarterback, besides when
I was super wrong about
Kellen Clemens years ago.
So where I'm at, you know there's no way
I'm doing anything with that.
I won't even touch that.
Okay, you're wearing it, good.
- This is my only revenge for Sunday.
- I gotta get out of
here 'cause I'm running,
but I will say this,
I'm excited to clip this
in 12 years and post it
on whatever the Instagram of
the day is, because I think,
look, he could get injured,
'cause that's sports.
I really think Darnold is
a top-tier quarterback.
Right now we have an atrocious
offensive line situation.
By the way, same reason
I think Daniel Jones
is a top-tier quarterback.
It's crazy to me, this
is a real fun story.
VaynerSports had a final meeting.
This is actually true story.
I haven't said this very often,
but I wanna give you some scoops
'cause I want your podcast to blow up.
I was in Sam Darnold's living room,
with his parents, pitching VaynerSports.
We got to the final meeting,
it was super cool, we
were a small company,
but using my leverage we got in the mix.
I said, "Sam, if I had the
ability to make the future happen
"and I had the choice of you
signing with VaynerSports
"and going number one
overall to the Browns,"
and then I said this, "And
let's be very clear here,
"you signing with VaynerSports
right now, for our business,
"would transcend our business.
"It would put us on the map in a way
"that nothing else could.
"Or you don't sign with us,
you go with CAA," which is
where I thought he was gonna
go and where he did go,
"And you go third to the Jets,
"I would have the second thing happen."
- Of course you did.
That's incredible.
- And that's who I think he is,
that's how much I care about the Jets
and that's what's happened.
And I'm pumped because I like adversity,
so I like that everyone's
taking a shit on us,
ghosts, mono, we suck.
The kid up here is a fuckin' beast.
He's a quiet kid, he's not Baker, right?
He's not gonna be that guy.
I couldn't believe more in his psyche
and his actual physical ability.
Now it's about building an offensive line,
getting some wins.
- What do you think, four years?
- Yeah, exactly.
Listen, I actually think
both of them, in a weird way,
and I hate to say this 'cause I hate
giving Giant fans credit, but
Eli had a big-time career.
- [Michael] Oh yeah.
- And I actually think
it's super weird that
both Sam and Daniel
remind me a lot of Eli.
Just cerebral.
- When Jones played his
first starting game.
- Was that Tampa?
- Yeah.
Number eight jersey, blue Giants Jersey,
was the number-one selling
jersey on NFL Shop.
- Yeah of course, make sense.
- That day for me, watching
him start that game
and win that game was
probably one of the best days
I can recall in the last-
- Of course, 'cause you start
going into, "Oh my God."
- There's hope!
- "We have 13 years of this!"
- [Michael] There's hope.
- Yeah of course.
- [Michael] And he's a pedigree.
- Bro, I don't know what else to tell you.
We recruited him before
his last year in college.
We completely believed,
we completely believed,
we thought he was the best
quarterback in that draft.
I still believe that to be true.
And I was pissed that the Giants took him.
- [Michael] Gary.
- Thank you.
- You're the man.
- Thank you brother.
- Thank you so much.
I gotta go, I'm super
late, I'm outta here.
(upbeat horn music)